the Joe Rogan experience how much you do
2:05 exactly
I'm gonna go piss but I'm supposed to be
like 195 from 195 would you get down to
in serve October you you posted
something what 194 stop birth - Tom wait
in like 2:30
oh yeah just just for the bit I'll do it
again but just tell him - what do you
want what are you what it's believable
that we could put you have to say 232
not 228 now I know that he won't believe
it sure yeah you weigh in and use lean
on me that's what they did it yeah
what the Calvin Gasland I don't know the
black did that a black I lost the [ __ ]
Daniel yeah it's been a core but no
Calvin leaned on teen on his manager
shoulder yeah do it do it do it train
train train train train train train
train in cheating cheating what is it
because it's not really cause either
rest is steady yeah you gotta like rest
steady make your shoulder hard just let
the charge which has channel okay is
back either he's back
no I think he's one of the best guys
I've ever met Oh
oh my god I get the hat off get the hat
off how much you carryin what's in
between the fat fold and the unfold
[Laughter]
wait a minute though wait but your
pulley
yeah to sweatsuit well hey guys it is
what it is
[ __ ] these are great pictures this is
great for your premiere date
[Applause]